well I'm joined Now by Dr Jordan
Peterson Jordan great to have you back
on the program a lot has happened since
you were last on just a few weeks ago I
want to start by saying that I I'm
wrestling with a lot of moral quandaries
about this war and I'm hoping that
through our conversation today we might
get to at least have some clarity about
the moral quandaries and see if we can
uh work out what we should be thinking
about this because I think it's very
complicated um and it's got to be
nuanced this conversation do you feel
any moral quandaries about
it well I don't think you can have a war
without moral quander I mean a war is
the consequence of an unsolvable moral
quander and
so it's not surprising that the
conversation surrounding the war is full
of moral queries because if if it was
straightforward and simple and if there
was an easy path forward then there
wouldn't be a war and so I mean
I'm I can tell you what I think is going
on to the degree that you can reduce it
to something quickly
explicable know I think Iran is
desperate because of the tenuous hold on
power that the mullers now have in Iran
given their own citizens Rebellion I
think they see the Abraham Accords which
were the most significant step for
forward towards peace in the Middle East
for like 75 years they see the Abraham
Accords as an existential threat this is
a last ditch attempt by the Iranian
mulas to use the Islam against Jews
story to prop up their own dismal Reign
and so they rattled the chain of their
Hamas puppets and said provoke and they
did and their hope is that the Israeli
response will be so overwhelming that
the Arab world turns against them and
maybe even the people who might be
inclined to know be swayed by a victim
narrative in the west and that the
Abraham Accords will fall apart and and
that'll be the end of that and that
could happen and I'm hoping it won't
because I think the Abraham Accords were
you know and it it's irritating to me
for whatever you you know utility that
is is that I think I know in so far as
you can know such things
that Saudi Arabia would have signed the
Abraham Accords 2 years ago if Biden
would have moved a little bit more
forthrightly on it and I think the
reason that he didn't and the Democrats
didn't was because they didn't want to
give Trump any credit for anything that
he had attained in his administration
and I think all of that is appalling and
you know I see this story of Muslim
against Jew being put forward in this
propagandistic manner and I think well
the Muslim world has to make a choice
too because does doesn't look to me like
their proper Champions are is the
government in Iran you know and and and
it's not like the Saudis don't have
their flaws and perhaps the rest of the
Arab governmental structures
but
the the Islam World should move in the
direction of the Abraham Accords that
would be great for everyone we could
have a real peace we could have
something approximating a union of the
abrahamic people and I think the Accord
was named extraordinarily well or we
could have what we've had for the last
75 years with the Palestinians as
Perpetual Canon F you know at the back
and call of those for whom having them
be Canon fodder is useful and so yeah
well there's just moral quandaries
everywhere there it's a Minefield but
that's what I think is the the
fundamental reality of the current
situation it's a propaganda war and
there's a lot at
stake on October the 7th
Hamas obviously committed a terror
attack of appalling magnitude where were
you when you first heard about it and
what was your instant feeling about
it well my instant feeling was to be
sickened by it you know it hasn't been
that long since I was in Jerusalem and
so it was a little closer to me than it
might have otherwise been um I'm also
more sensitive to any signs of
anti-Semitic catastrophe from
studying the Holocaust for the length of
time that I did and I've always regarded
Jews as the canary and the coal mine and
I think the reason that the Jews are the
Canary and the coal mine is because
they're a successful minority you know
and if a if a culture can tolerate a
successful minority it's pretty damn
robust and it's not very resentful and
as soon as a culture starts to get
resentful the Jews make an easy target
because they're a minority and so that's
an easy target to begin with but then
they're the minority that has the tarity
to be successful that really brings the
resentful out of the Rat holes and I've
seen arise an anti-Semitism online over
the last three years it's just stunning
to behold on the right and on the left
jointly and then well so I was sickened
by it but then I was also immediately
suspicious of Iran's role and I mean
that doesn't require any particular
perspicacity on my part I think it's
quite obvious but but I that also open
up the The Rat's Nest of of the
maneuvering the political maneuvering
around the Abraham Accords because you
know I was very ill when the Abraham
Accords were signed and I couldn't or
hadn't paid much attention and when I
sort of recovered my ability to see
again I saw that this remarkable peace
process had taken place and I could not
understand for the life of me why it
wasn't trumpeted on the front page of
every newspaper across the world and I
also think that Trump's team should have
got a Nobel Peace Prize for it I I
cannot see how you can possibly make a
counterargument to that for all of
Trump's flaws and for his
administration's flaws this was a major
accomplishment and yet and I know the
Saudis were behind it you know they
didn't sign it but it wouldn't have gone
forward without their nod and wink and I
know I believe that if Biden would have
taken the opportunity and been a bit
magnanimous in his response to Trump
which he could have been instead of
thinking of him as Satan himself that he
could have enticed the Saudis into a
peace Accord we wouldn't be in this damn
situation now and now we're playing it
out the hard way you know because the
Iranians could win the propaganda war
and they've got God only knows how many
agents they have in the west you know
promoting the kind of social upheaval
that we've seen on the streets in the
last few weeks and so the narrative
could go either way but I'm rooting hard
for the for the Abraham Accord SES and I
hope they have the courage of their
convictions and I hope they can see that
their way forward is the most
appropriate Way Forward
for the good of the Muslim
world or what are we going to stay in
some 14th century conflict between the
fundamentalist Muslim world and the and
the Jews Jesus that sounds you know
we've had enough of that haven't we
you'd think I asked Ben
Shapiro what what is the proportionate
response to what happened on October 7th
and he said there isn't one that there
is no proportionate response and there
shouldn't be
I mean that in itself you I asked V
ramaswami uh when I interviewed him at
the weekend the same question and he was
basically inferring the same but he also
said that um you know he would happily
put the heads of a hundred Hamas leaders
on Stakes along the border as a message
to people uh not to commit this act I
thought that was a a sort of medieval
barbaric response to Med medieval
barbarism and that I ey for an eye tooth
for tooth is not the solution I also
believe that Israel has a fundamental
right not just to defend itself after
what happened but has a duty to protect
its people and it has to take that Duty
obviously very seriously but if you if
your mission statement as they've made
clear is to eliminate Hamas completely
and Hamas live in the in Gaza surrounded
by civilians among civilians you can
only do that you can only get rid of
Hamas with massive civilian casualties
and that's where I have this moral
quandry about how much is too much well
does Israel get a license to do whatever
it wants to eliminate Hamas or should
there be a limit and if so what is that
limit well I don't think Israel will
have a license to do whatever it wants
because what will happen inevitably and
I I think if I was an Iranian
propagandist I would be counting on this
let's imagine that Israel moves against
Hamas with its usual
Effectiveness and they start winning you
know in a serious way and the casuales
mount well it's a lot easier to take a
victim appreciation stance against a
power that's clearly winning so Israel
can't win without acing losses along the
way because the more they manifest their
M military
superiority the easier it's going to be
for those who cast the Palestinians as
victims to hold to gain the moral upper
hand and so and that doesn't mean I know
what Israel should do because I wish I
had that wisdom but what I would like to
see happen in the best of all possible
worlds perhaps would be for the Sines of
the Abraham Accords to say to Israel
privately first we're not budging and
then maybe
and then maybe to take a foray into the
public and say that it would be lovely
to see Saudi Arabia and come out and say
you
know we're going to continue the Abraham
peace Accord
process and then Israel could say well
if the Abraham Accord holds and we have
the probability of expanding it we can
take the risk of not being so
devastating in our response to Hamas and
they could back off but because there'd
be there'd be a counter victory in it
for them and so as far like I can't see
a better pathway forward than that and I
think that's a potentially realistic
pathway especially because that would
also have the side benefit
of not allowing Iran to
Prevail so that's that's the best I can
do on on how this might proceed in the
in the most optimistic possible way and
I don't know if that's good enough or
not
on October the 7th you tweeted give them
hell Netanyahu enough is enough and you
got some blowback for that as everybody
a lot says anything about this were you
surprised by the scale of the blowback
do you wish you'd phrase that tweet
differently do you have any regrets
about
well you know Twitter is a very
complicated social media platform and
it's been difficult for me to learn how
to use it wisely and I'm not alone in
that because it's difficult to be wise
on Twitter now what I'm trying to learn
is when a tweet is appropriate and when
a long form commentary is appropriate
and the rule I think is something like
the higher the stakes the more likely
that the long form commentary is
necessary and really it would have been
better had
I because I did release a YouTube video
where I explained some of what we
already talked about I sense that yeah
yeah and that was well that was received
much better let's put it that way but it
also gave me a chance to elaborate my
argument and so what it highlighted for
me and I felt you know I was look I
wasn't I was very taken back by what
happened
in in Israel and I was also appalled
because in my estimation it was
unnecessary as I said the Abraham
Accords could have been extended earlier
and maybe this would would it be
necessary um and
so I I I allowed myself to express some
sentiment at that point without
providing context and that wasn't as
good as providing the context and
so and I'm rethinking Twitter overall at
the moment about how to use it you know
Elon has taken off the character limit
and he's also made it possible to
distribute video and so it no longer has
to be a place where impulsive exchanges
can can occur rapidly and I'm trying to
reconfigure how I use it I'm much
happier with the video now you know I
was upset because I had developed
somewhat of a Muslim following um on
YouTube and I was very happy about that
a lot of people on the Islamic side of
the world were watching my biblical
lectures for example and you know and
I've had extensive conversations with
Muslims on my YouTube channel and you
know I burnt some of that up and I'm not
sure I did that well I I would say I'm
certain I didn't do that in the most
productive Manner and
so do I regret
it it would have been better to do the
long form to to have done the long form
to begin with you know and Twitter
invites and rewards a certain amount of
impulsivity and it
wasn't I don't know Pierce I don't know
if it's ever time for impulsive action
especially when the stakes are serious
you know yeah and so no I I I completely
get that I was I mean there's no doubt
for example that what happened October
the 7th was a form of hell for the
victims uh and for their families um
there's also no doubt that for many
living in Gaza for many innocent
Palestinians is as we know of the 2
million or so uh residents citizens
there
they I think it's more than half are of
child age and many are very young
children and many children are getting
killed and as a father I'm sure as like
me as a father it is utterly
heartbreaking to see so many thousands
of children being killed who have
nothing obviously to do with this uh
again this this comes back to this moral
con I have um you know was interesting
when you said enough is enough in that
tweet you know some people are already
saying even if they're very sympathetic
to Israel's need to take out Hamas
they're looking at these fairly
apocalyptic scenes in Gaza and thinking
enough is enough of that you know in
other words that this the revenge is
already far greater in terms of death
toll than the original appalling Terror
attacks that again is where I have a
moral quandry well the the question is I
suppose and I don't purport to have an
answer to this is the most effective way
of combating Hamas military and part of
the answer to that is is the military
eradication of Hamas even possible
because as I said and we can see it
unfolding in real time as Israel is more
successful militarily and the casualties
Mount the resistance to what they're
doing is going to grow yeah and so even
if they could take out Hamas militarily
which isn't obvious given its
interpenetration with the civilian
population it all of what's going to be
played out is going to be played out on
the military front and we can see that
in the rising tide let's say of
demonstrations around the Western world
and I would say those demonstrations are
likely to get larger and more effective
in precise proportion to Israel
success on the military side and so then
I would think well is there another way
of restraining Hamas and well that's
again that brings us back to the Abraham
Accords because they were the most
promising thing that's happened in seven
decades you know and I think it's it's
easy to underestimate what a miracle
they were the people who formulated the
Abraham Accords had to fight the state
department they tried to introduce it
under Obama to begin with right the in
notion was well maybe we could we could
start the peace process cess with Israel
without putting the Palestinians first
and that had been off the table
conceptually in the state department as
far as I've been informed forever and
and then it was proposed during the
Obama era and it was rejected and then
it was proposed during the beginning of
the Trump era and rejected but
eventually they They Carried the day and
then they did do an endr run and I think
that actually put I think that was
actually good for for the typical
Palestinian
because it put a tremendous amount of
pressure on the Palestinian authorities
who are basically tyrants who are more
than willing to use their own citizens
as Canon f it put a lot of pressure on
them to actually do something moving
moving towards a genuine peace which is
why now Iran that's why Iran is so
desperate to scuttling Accords I think
of course you know so I think the way
through ham Hamas all things considered
in the medium to long run is to
desperately extend the Abraham Accords
as rapidly as possible that's not a
military Victory
but you know when to do this from the
armure when you look at the full history
of this conflict the seven decades of of
of conflict between Israel and and
Palestinians Jonathan Friedland is a is
a very good uh respected Jewish
journalist uh for the guardian in the UK
he wrote a very interesting column the
other day saying you know you could
argue that both both sides have a just
cause here he said that as a leading
Jewish commentator that historically
both sides have a just cause and that
it's important to remember that and
that's why passions run so high it's why
people care so much and it's why racing
to take
sides uh is a mistake in this conflict
what do you think of
that well I think that you know if there
wasn't a lot to be said on both both
sides then the conflict wouldn't drag on
forever and be
unresolvable know I think at some point
you do something like cut the gordian
knot which I do think to some degree the
Abraham Accords had begun to do you know
I think it's I don't think Israel's
going
away but I don't think the pales pal
Palestine isn't going away either and so
those things have to be accepted I it
looks to me like they have to be
accepted as on the ground reality
now the the problem I've seen
continually I don't know is that it's
been convenient to use the Palestinians
as an irritant to Israel in the west and
so the Palestinians have been held
hostage you know the people who portray
them as innocent victims presume that
the Palestinians have been held hostage
by the Jews let's say but I would say
even more effectively by their own
leadership and by those who are
perfectly will willing to use use them
as the front man the Expendable frontman
to irritate Israel in the west well you
can't get peace under those
circumstances you know and
so Palestine is a reality that isn't
going to go away and Israel is a reality
that isn't going to go away and the
Abraham Accords started to recognize
that and there was move in the right
direction and if that falls apart we're
going to be back to where we were yeah
15 years ago except worse the
interesting moment for me came when
Israel turned off the power and the
water um they just were able to do that
to 2 million people in Gaza they could
turn off the internet and it struck me
that that was a very Vivid reminder that
Israel effectively controls Gaza it
doesn't do so politically but it does in
reality and that for many young people
in Gaza they know this and they do feel
that they've been living in a Perpetual
prison camp where their movement is
controlled where their access to basic
things like water and energy and so on
is controlled uh and that until they get
the freedom that they crave this can
never get resolved but I also understand
on the other side that the Israelis feel
how can we give freedom to a place that
is run by a terror group who are
literally committed to the eradication
of not only Israel but all Jewish people
well you laid out you laid out what are
the two sets of valid counter claims I
mean there's another complicating Factor
too you know you you said that you you
know your moral back is up because of
the
continual toll in civilians in Palestine
especially among people who let's say
weren't even born when they first came
to power and so it's very difficult to
look at that and see it as any anything
but unjust but then it begs a whole
other set of questions too doesn't it
it's like well if your government is a
totalitarian band of armed criminal
thugs what responsibility do you bear
for that as as the subjected people and
you know it's not like I know the answer
to that but you know I see in my own
country in Canada that things are
slipping and sliding in all sorts of
pathological directions and people are
letting it happen and if you let that
happen long enough well things get very
very bad and they have got very very bad
in Palestine and the answer to whatever
tyranny Israel might be exerting over
the Palestinians isn't for the
Palestinians to exert even more tyranny
over themselves especially not in
concert with a third party like Iran
who's perfectly willing to sacrifice
them at any point and so now and then
that question emerges well what
responsibility did the Palestinians bear
well then I think we start to touch on
more metaphysical issues it's like well
the Palestinians like all people bear
the responsibility to live in truth and
to stand up to tyranny in their in their
deeds their attention and their deeds
and their actions because if you don't
you pay for that and so do your children
right and then so to your grandchildren
so to your great-grandchildren and you
know there seems to be something unjust
in that in that why did the children
suffer and the biblical answer to that
has always been well the children suffer
for the sins of their forefathers and
you might think well it's pretty unfair
that the world is set up that way it's
like hey it might be unfair but it is
set up that way and it does beg the
question what responsibility did the
people who are living under the thumb of
totalitarians have for the fact that
they're living under the thumb of
totalitarians and the answer isn't
none
so this is why I'm a psychologist not a
politician I no no but it's no but I
think I think it's I think it's a really
interesting question it's also an
interesting question why why won't Arab
states around Gaza taking Palestinian
refugees I mean these are legitimate
questions right well there's a lot of
there's a lot of chain and saber
rattling about how tyrannical Israel is
and of course they're held to a very
higher moral standard but you know the
prison that is Palestine has walls on
sides that aren't Israeli so and that no
one is certainly not the progressives
will never talk about that and that's
partly because you know all the
oppressed people are equally morally
virtuous and so the fact that the Arabs
won't take in the Palestinians you can't
even bring that up because of course the
Arabs themselves are victims of Western
colonialism which is you know one of the
most absurd propositions ever set forth
by anyone about anything but you know
here we
are and it is quite a miracle in some
ways that that the the multi-dimensional
fact of Palestinian enslavement isn't
discussed in a much more forthright
manner there's many people are building
the walls that that make Palestine into
whatever prison it is and perhaps the
Israelis are playing their role but
they're by no means the only
actors let's talk about the response of
progressives and in particular what's
happening on student campuses
particularly in America you know I've
been stropped by by two things one the
horrifying immediate response not just
in America but when you saw mobs in
Sydney Australia chanting gas the Jews
when you saw huge protests by the
Israeli Embassy in Kensington and West
London near where I live um all
celebrating this is all within hours of
what happened on October the 7th you saw
similar scenes in America um so the gut
reaction of many young people appeared
to be to be celebrating what had
happened and you even had some there was
a Cornell uh Professor who you know was
heard in public saying how exhilarated
he was by what happened and still hasn't
been fired um and these are people
who've driven this cancel culture for
many years now where if you use the
wrong pronoun they want you eradicated
fired shamed abused and so on um but
here if you celebrate the actions of a
terrorist organization and killing 1500
people you actually don't lose your job
students who beamed pramas rhetoric onto
the building at George washingon
University they haven't lost their
places at that University so even for
the most heinous possible thing that you
could do which might warrant
cancellation the people who've driven
cancel culture spare
themselves well this shows you how
shallow the oppressor oppress oppression
oppressor narrative really is oppressed
oppressor narrative really is you know
George Orwell famously said that the
typical middleclass socialists didn't
love the poor they just hated the rich
and I think the oppressor oppressed
narrative gives people moral license to
identify the oppressor and to hate them
resentfully with a good conscience plus
it's also extremely simple-minded you
know and this is one of the problems
with with what's being taught in
universities and even much more broadly
than that now the notion is we can view
all human social relations and the past
itself through a metam Marxist narrative
that proclaims that there are only
oppressors and victims and that all you
have to do to be moral is to be on the
side of the victim now the shadow side
of that is that once you Proclaim your
moral superiority and you're on the side
of the victim well number one you don't
have to think anymore you just have to
identify the two sets of players and
number two number two you're moral
without effort because all you have to
do is feel sorry for the victims and
then consequence number three is the
oppressor being intrinsically evil can
be the target of everything that's
resentful and bitter and absolutely
Dreadful about you now that's the
standard narrative that's being taught
on University campuses and the
Palestinians play the role of victim and
so you can't argue against the
Palestinian cause let's say if if you
were inclined to without simultaneously
having to face the weight of every
single person who's adopted the
oppressor oppressed narrative upending
that and there's no way the university
not in the not not the state they're in
now there's no way that's going to fly
and so and so we see exactly what
happened the narrative is already in
place all oppressed people are innocent
and virtuous victims
well so then when something like this
happens and you see the Palestinian
victims rise up against their evil
Jewish overlords then it's time for
celebration you know and we forget
entirely that the evil Jewish Overlord
story was the same story that the
Germans used so successfully and we also
forget and this is very interested in
relationship to Iran I was reading a
book by Stan zag yesterday about turn of
the century Vienna just at the end of
the Austrian Hungarian Empire and the
dawning of the movements that eventually
morphed into Nazism in Germany and one
of the things V pointed out was that you
know if you're a corrupt oppressing
psychopath who's hellbent on exploiting
the population and you want to deflect
that the Jews make a constant positive
Universal Target right because they tend
to be disproportionately successful and
you can just say well you know I'm not
the oppressor here it's those successful
Jews and that's being played out now
that's that's that's the guise that's
the disguise of left-wing anti-Semitism
I mean so Terri we don't hate the Jews
we just love their enemies right I mean
the the anti-semitic response in the
last three weeks has been actually quite
terrifying to watch I've got Jewish
friends who are literally living in real
fear now um some of whom were in Israel
at the time and thought well the world
will rally behind us and actually very
quickly realize that they many cases
that wasn't the case in fact the
complete opposite uh and then you saw
these scenes in dagistan at the airport
with a mob literally charging around
trying to find any Jewish passengers
they could find and it was I mean
horrendous but also if you're Jewish
this is utterly terrifying and must take
you right back to Nazi Germany World War
II the
Holocaust this never again it it is
beginning to happen again well I think
we could be heartened in that regard by
the counter position though too I mean I
would
say the the reasonable majority in the
western world didn't take that stance
still and quite forthrightly I mean even
my prime minister Justin Trudeau who
virtually never says a true word in his
life or makes a he his his actions or
conc continuations of false gestures
even you know he was he came out with a
pretty forthright statement um decrying
what had happened on the Hamas side and
that has characterized the leadership of
the West in general and so I can
certainly understand why the the tiny
minority of Jews that do exist in the
world are terrified about what's
happening you know it it there's there's
no reason for cast atrophic alarm it's
you know what I mean it it doesn't look
to me like this is going to spiral out
of control and I'm not even so certain
that in the medium to long run it's
going to be the worst possible thing
because you know too the other thing
that happened is that a lot of the false
moral disguise of the progressive types
was exposed in a radical way in the last
few weeks I mean Harvard for example
just took a beating you know I mean
first of all Harvard was ranked dead
last by fire in terms of it support for
free speech and then it was 32 different
Harvard groups came out essentially in
support of Hamas and then a whole
variety of CEOs said they wouldn't
accept the Harvard degree as a hiring
criteria and Larry Summers came out and
said you know the previous president of
Harvard that the institution had become
so corrupt that it wasn't salvageable
then you know the White House Press
Secretary decried the actions of the
squad who were supporting the Hamas
protests you know so we're seeing cracks
on the Progressive side because of this
that haven't been evident before you
know and and Biden himself came out and
talked about how important it was to
push forward with the Abraham Accords
which was something you know I wish he
would have done two years ago but better
late than never so I can understand why
there's tremendous fear and uncertainty
but I certainly wouldn't say that all
the news is
bad let talk about social media for a
moment we there's no doubt that the kind
of tribalism that we see in modern
society fueled by social media has
probably never been worse than I've seen
it in the last three weeks a constant
barrage of often completely fake imagery
videos claims counter claims from both
sides um but it's just a barrage and
I've been really quite shocked by just
the scale of it and how little of it
appears to even have a semblance of of
truth about it what do we do what do we
do about this well that highlights that
highlights a a a very pronounced danger
so you know in the last 15 years we've
erected virtual perceptual systems and
virtual systems virtual systems of
representing reality now if your system
of representing reality is not in accord
with reality you're delusional and right
technically that's what a delusion is
and you're going to run into trouble
when you try to act in your fantasy and
run into the world well these Virtual
Worlds that we've erected on top of the
real world don't run by the same
principles as the real world and that
makes them delusional and that
delusional element is affecting us very
badly in a couple of ways I just heard
Jonathan height this morning talk about
some of the re research he's reviewing
in his new book he shows very clearly
that young liberal women the probability
that young liberal woman who saturates
her life with social media has a mental
illness is more than 50% that's how bad
it's got yeah it's really bad but that's
not the only thing that's going on you
see the other thing I've been watching
and this is really quite frightening to
me is
that the problem with online one of the
problems with online communication is it
disinhibits the narcissists and the
Psychopaths and the reason for that is
that they can circumvent the normal
control systems that obtain in
face-to-face interaction yes you know
and in face-to-face interaction there's
things you will not say or do because
you will be held responsible and maybe
immediately you can say whatever the
hell you want online and you can get
away with it too and maybe even be
rewarded for it and so we have so you
just think about the amount of
criminality and quasi criminality online
35% of internet traffic is pornographic
and it isn't nice guys that are running
that let's put it that way there's an
immense amount of online criminality
like most people are targeted by online
criminals on a pretty regular basis and
then we just have the run-ofthe-mill
narcissistic Psychopaths who generate
Anonymous troll demon accounts who who
are spreading misery and sadistic hate
as fast as they possibly can and there's
no barriers whatsoever to them doing
that and so then when something does
happen that's contentious let's say the
sadistic Psychopaths just make hay out
of that right they're spreading their
misery as rapidly as they possible
possibly can for the lulls and the
lulles and to Delight in other people's
suffering and the social media companies
are naive enough not to regulate that
now regulating it's difficult but but
it's a conversation we have to have
Pierce because I think like if we let
the Psychopaths that's 4% of the
population whenever they get the upper
hand and that happens from time to time
Everything Burns I also think that young
young people in particular um they are
exposed to such relentless
dopamine imagery both still pictures
videos whatever um and in particular the
last three weeks if you're a young
person with an impressionable mind and
you're getting bombarded with some of
the worst imagery imaginable you know
babies dead um limbless and so on if
you're getting that on your feed all day
long which I'm seeing on mine so they
must be it can only have an incredibly
damaging effect to to I think a young
generation already ripped with anxiety
ripped with problems about how to deal
with the real world and I think a lot of
it is they're just seeing so much bad
stuff all the time on social media which
when I was young you just couldn't see
it you would not be able to access this
kind of thing you were protected in a
way from the reality of things like
Warfare um and protected from this kind
of
imagery yeah well again it's it's a
problem of technological Revolution
because this new sensory system that
we've produced this new system of
perception it's a fire hose first of all
that's impossible to govern you can
never get on top of it it's it's
infinite in its scope yeah and then it
allows the pathological and the terrible
to spread as rapidly as the beneficial
and the good and so it is overwhelming
it's not just kids that have a hard time
with that I mean it's just these
Technologies well what do we expect
they're insanely powerful and remarkable
but carry with it the well they carry
with
it all of the implications of that
insane power on the pathological side
and we don't exactly know how to deal
with it we don't know how to Reg we
haven't evolved the social norms even
that regulate online conduct you know I
mean when I block people on Twitter
let's say I have qualms about it you
know well I'm in favor of free speech do
I block trolls online and when exactly
do I block them you know I've got more
direct about that I have a couple of
rules you know if you're anonymous if
you're anonymous and you're annoying
it's like you're done as far as I'm
concerned but but that's just the
beginnings of the evolution of anything
approximating social saying I've
wrestled with that because I've blocked
I think 11,000 people or whatever it is
I can't remember what the latest tally
is um I go on little block spurges
sometimes but to me there's no
contradiction between uh believing
passionately in free speech but also
allow yourself not to have to listen to
it you don't have to listen to what
people are saying to you you you have
the right in a in a free Democratic
Society to say look you're entitled to
say whatever you want but I don't
actually have to listen to it that's not
you're not preventing them from
exercising their right to free speech
you're just saying I don't want to hear
it that's why that's why we have walls
like that that's a good example of the
difference between the virtual world and
the real world you have a house and it
has walls and a door
and the reason for that is you don't
want a random stranger to come in and
just yell things at you whenever you
know and so what are the walls and the
doors on social media well we have no
idea because we thought well we'll
democratize the Public Square okay so
what does that mean it means that any
narcissistic psychopath anywhere can say
whatever they want to you and everyone
you know well you know that's just not
going to work it's not going to work
there always been criminals and quasi
criminals and troublemakers and we have
some mechanisms of regulation in the
actual world and virtually no re
mechanisms of Regulation whatsoever on
the v in the virtual world and so yeah
it's a it's a tremendous problem and it
it is also making it more and more
difficult for us to distinguish what's
real from what's not real because you
don't know when you're being played for
a what would you call masochistic Fool
by a sadistic psychopath and the answer
to that is often often yeah you know
frighteningly often and
so my sense like I I proposed this
before is like I don't I think social
media um Enterprises above a certain
size should separate people with
verified identities verified by their
site not with some universal digital ID
separate them from the anonymous types
like if the anonymous types want to post
no problem but they shouldn't get to
post with the actual human
beings because there's no responsibility
you know and then you say well you know
maybe I'm a whistleblower and I'm I'm
standing for truth and I don't want to
Bear an undue responsibility for telling
truth to power it's like my sense online
is for every one whistleblower who's
genuine who's Anonymous there's 999
Anonymous troll demons who are sadistic
right yeah that's not a good
ratio you interviewed uh BB Netanyahu
quite recently actually a few months ago
um a lot of pressure on him internally a
lot of criticism uh Hamas released a
video uh on Monday of some of the
hostages attacking netanyahu's
Administration for for not having a
ceasefire and so on that was clear
propaganda but it also reflects what a
lot of people in Israel feel about net
Yahoo and the catastrophic failure of
security and defense on October the 7th
he's resolutely refused to accept any
responsibility or to apologize for that
do you think he
should well I I guess I wouldn't presume
to know I mean my observation about that
was that you know people said well how
could this happen how could the Israeli
defense systems be that porous and I
would say our defense systems are way
more porous than anybody would ever want
to think you know it's very very
difficult to stop people who are willing
to light themselves on fire to singe you
and any random person in a civilized
society can cause an unbelievable amount
of Mayhem and trouble and in order to
Forstall that possibility completely
which would be impossible in any case
we'd have to move towards a surveillance
State like China where we're being
monitored 100% of the time and then the
bloody cure would be worse than the
disease it doesn't surprise me that
Israel's defense was that poorest I
don't think it I don't think it cannot
be in a society that's still vaguely
free and even if you lock people down
Jesus you can still cause a lot of
trouble if you're hellbent on doing it
so does Net should Netanyahu apologize
for the failures of the Israeli defense
system in relationship to the Hamas
attack I don't know enough to say it
isn't obvious to me that it failed any
worse than you should expect a system
like that that to fail when it's faced
by Psychopathic terrorists who are being
funded by outside sources who want to do
nothing else but cause misery in Mayhem
so I interviewed Neta who partly because
I wanted to talk to him because I was
curious and I was also an admirer of his
economic reforms the economic reforms
that I think did raise Israel to this
position of of pronounced economic power
and entrepreneurial capacity that they
now possess which also made them a more
attractive partner during the Abraham
ACC cours because the Israelis had the
possibility of offering to the Arabs the
sharing of their technology and their
entrepreneurial and managerial prowess
they had something to offer along with
their you know military strength so I
thought that was all to the good I don't
know enough about Netanyahu and about
the intricacies of Israel politics God
it's hard enough to keeping track of my
own country you know to to dare to to
say anything more than that I'm glad I'm
not in his shoes how about that that's
you know I can't imagine there's
anything about that that's that's
anything other than abysmally difficult
nonstop so let's turn Jordan to the ark
conference it's why you're in London and
I'm actually in Los Angeles at the
moment um The Alliance for responsible
citizenship this is your brainchild a
huge event a lot of very interesting
speakers from all around the world
um you've made it clear it's it's driven
by a desire to be motivational rather
than political explain
that well I I've traveled all over the
world and met hundreds of thousands of
people um in various ways and listened
to them and watched them and
sampled public sentiment to the degree I
was capable and that was overwhelming as
we've discussed before I had no idea
really like I had a clinical practice
and I was pretty damn familiar with a
reasonable swath of the scope of human
misery but I didn't understand how
widespread the sense of demoralization
had become especially among young people
and and and I got a real taste of that
and um I'm tired of the Zero Sum
apocalyptic fear-mongering story I don't
buy it I don't think any bit of it is
useful I think it's extremely convenient
who want to use the crisis to acre power
to themselves and I think that the
leader who motivates with fear is a
tyrant and the leader might say well
there's something to be afraid of and I
would say yeah there's always something
to be afraid of you know and does the
apocalypse lurk in the future it's like
yes that's always been the case so
what's ark's premises well there's two
one is you have a moral obligation to be
optimistic about the
future that and that's that's a strange
statement right and it's actually a
statement of faith because I would say
just as you have an obligation to be
courageous about the challenges that
confront you in the present and and just
as that's the best way of dealing with
those challenges your default attitude
towards the future should be bring it on
we can handle it and I would also say
that if that is your default at attitude
you're much more likely to be successful
in your dealings with the future and one
of the things I've learned about
classic religious or metaphysical faith
is that a tremendous proportion of that
is the faith that is courage right the
courage to confront the unknown in the
future with standing up straight with
shoulders back right with the
presumption that despite our flaws we're
intrinsically good despite the misery in
the world it's intrinsically good and
that that's the relationship we should
establish with it so that's the first
part of the Ark motivational message and
the second part is that part of the way
that you face the future in a manner
that makes of it the best it could be is
to do that
responsibly to take responsibility for
yourself to put your life together to
tell the truth to pursue high order aims
to take responsibility for your marital
partner and vice versa to do the same
with your family your local community
your town your city and that's your
identity that nested Social Web of
obligations that's your identity and and
also that the meaning in your life is
going to emerge as a consequence of
shouldering that responsibility the
meaning and the adventure in your life
and so confront the future with faith
and courage and accept the
responsibility that's commensurate with
that and that's the way you set the
world straight and that's not a
political Solution that's a spiritual
solution or a psychological solution now
it has political ramifications but we're
much more interested at ARC and at the
AR conference with the with the
underlying substrate the substrate about
which the culture war is really
raging right about the the ultimate
nature of reality in some in some way
and and how you on how you construe that
I think to some degree you have to
construe it as a matter of Faith because
we're all ignorant and limited in our
knowledge and so we have to make first
pass approximations at what we're going
to presume to be true and so one set of
presumptions is open your eyes confront
what frightens you move forward
stalwartly aim up tell the truth there's
no evidence that that's correct but you
can start with that as a set of
propositions and then you could also
make the claim you the claim and I think
this is a valid claim you cannot canot
be armed better in life other than with
that set of propositions and I think
that's the Western claim and that's what
we're trying to communicate to the
degree we can with this AR conference
well I think it's an excellent uh an
excellent start I mean no more than that
let's see how people respond to it I was
encouraged actually uh in the last few
days by the news breaking here in
Hollywood that Disney have decided to
put back the release of their new
version of Snow White and the Seven
Dwarves by a year following the huge
backclash to the fact that actually it
as it wasn't going to have any dwarves
in it I think one the rest were going to
be fully bodied people male female black
white so on and so on tiing every
possible virtue signaling box and I
actually interviewed one of the leading
dwarf actors in the world who said how
dare they put me out of work like this
this is one of the most prized jobs in
the world for any dwarf actor being in
Snow White and the Seven Dwarves and it
was a very good point of course that in
their surge towards supposed equality
they were actually stopping the very
people for whom this would have been the
number one gig in town from getting that
gig but they've now put it back and
apparently are going to go back to
potentially even using CGI actual
dwarves in the movie
which seems to me a significant climb
down by Disney what do you make of this
well I think it's actually it's
perversely analogous to the case that
we're trying to make at ARC so there is
an underlying metaphysical or narrative
reality and you can warp and bend that
with an ideology but the ideology
doesn't map well onto the underlying
reality and
so that that's and and so how would that
play out in the case of Snow White in
the 7 to Wars well that's a very old
story and some some folktales we have
anthropological evidence that some
folktales can be up to 10 15,000 years
old extremely old well there's a reason
that they lay themselves out the way
they do it's it's the it's the logic of
the narrative world so I can give an
example with Snow White well why is Snow
White surrounded by dwarves when she
reaches the peak of her beauty why is
she surrounded by dwarves why do they
have to be dwarves and the answer is
a stellar young
woman finds herself surrounded by
dwarfs right that's the universal that's
the universal position of an extremely
well put together young woman there's
going to be men around her who aren't
what they could be right they're much
smaller than they need to be and why is
she waiting for a prince well cuz she's
a princess that's why and so you're
going to be waiting and this is the
Eternal situ situation of women they're
they're going to be waiting for not only
their match but for maybe for someone
that they actually admire and that's not
to be found around the dwarfs now you
can't just take that and say well let's
throw some random diversity people in
there it's like the story has a
coherence and the coherence
transcends easy understanding you know
it wouldn't have that magical mythical
element that fairy tales have if if the
narrative didn't transcend the
understanding one of the things we're
trying to do with Ark is to remind
people that our civilization exists in a
metaphysic in a story right it's a
Divine story and that the Divine story
has its reasons the reasons that
transcend reason it's it's where Carl
Yung the the famous psychoanalyst he he
his notion of the way the world worked
in in to simplify it to some degree is
there are things that are absolutely
beyond our
comprehension and then there are things
that we understand explicit ly and in
detail but there's a border between them
so so imagine there's not a cut off line
so you go from things you understand
completely to things you understand not
at all the border is the land of the
dream the land of the story The Land of
the fantasy the land of myth it's half
unknown and mysterious like the lands in
The Lord of the Rings and it's half
explicit and understandable and it's the
place that that the unknown moves
through before it becomes
explicit our Western philosophical
tradition with its Reliance on rights
let's say and its insistence upon the
Dignity of each individual exists within
a dreamlike metaphysic and that is the
judeo-christian story now we don't know
what to make of that rationally but it
fills a gap that and if you tear it out
or or transform it into an ideology all
that happens is half-formed pathological
fantasies take its place and that's
what's happening everyone's sees this
you know and nature predicted it in the
late 1870s or thereabouts you know God
will die and the realm of ideology will
rise up to take its place and if you
think that Christianity or or Judaism
was superstitious and insane it's like
just wait till you see what replaces it
and so that's well exact that's exactly
what we're seeing and it's happening
very very rapidly and everyone has that
sense this art conference the Press
coverage has actually been quite
interesting because even on the leftwing
side I wouldn't say it's been laudatory
on the leftwing side but it's been it's
been pretty evenhanded and neutral which
is quite remarkable and the reason for
that I think Pierce is that people are
so tired of the Endless diet of
nihilistic apocalypse yeah that even
those who don't can't see their way out
of it rationally hope that something
else could be be provided as an
alternative Dr Jordan Peterson uh what a
fascinating hour thank you very much
indeed for joining me and best of luck
with the the conference I think it's a
great idea it's a great thing to get
people with good ideas together even if
they're bad ideas actually just debate
ideas um and to have a positive theme of
how we can make things better not worse
get away from nalism get the opposite of
nism into the ideology of the world
would be a great starting block so I
thank you very much indeed my pleasure
yeah well it's good to know that it
might be courage that's the opposite of
nihilism yes absolutely yeah thank you
very much hey thank you it's always a
pleasure to talk to you
pierce